rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une randonnée sur la planète du maïdo le
piton rouge au départ de la route
forestière des tamarins
rendez vous sur la route forestière du
maïdo au dessus de la chaloupe saint leu
au départ du sentier nous retrouvons
bien la porte du parc national
sur la planète du maïdo il existe tout
un réseau de sentiers vers le piton
rouge qui rappelle celle vers la
glacière traverse une zone de marronnage
ou aurait vécu le roi fahd ans dont on
aurait retrouvé la tombe
ça
même si
et
soumise aux incendies la planète est
aujourd'hui menacée par la prolifération
d'espèces exotiques le long de pistes
forestières récente c'est une nouvelle
plante qui pose problème c'est le cas
sial ou l'acacia l'acacia mais ramzy
donc qui a tendance beckett a paru il ya
quelques années et qui prend une grosse
envergure notamment le long de ce bord
de piste ce genre de piste là et il a
une croissance extrêmement rapide là des
individus comme ça nous on les a vus au
pouce et l'ajustement en trois ans
depuis les incendies de 2011 et voilà
sont des espaces qui profitent des
ouvertures des milieux comme ça le
problème des invasif et de la lutte
contre les invasive c'est toujours le il
nous faudrait vraiment beaucoup de
partenaires qui est des missions
vraiment commune avec beaucoup de
partenaires et qu'ils soient répétées
dans le temps très régulièrement et pour
l'instant les l'organisation fait que
bah c'est difficile de mettre ce genre
de choses en place le long du sentier
les traces des incendies sont encore
bien visibles pourtant de nombreux
branle vers adultes semblent avoir été
épargnées
on a un petit cordon la de brasles
l'erika réunionnais n'zi ce qui fait une
taille correcte d'environ un mètre et
qui donc cédé des branches qui ont
encore une dizaine d'années
ça permet de d'imaginer le mouvement
d'une vague de flamme qui serait venu
lécher les l'ébranler ça montre en fait
que la 110 a pu
à certains moments arrivé jusque là et
puis sur une seconde main sur sur
quelques heures seulement changer de
direction reporter dans un autre dans
une autre direction en fait voilà c'est
aussi simple que ça cette alternance de
bois calcinées de zones épargnées de
zones où la végétation reprend doucement
ses droits crête un paysage morcelé de
couleurs différentes
kiffer
il
une ambiance particulière surtout quand
viennent s'ajouter des bosquets de petit
tamarin des hauts endémique d'un verre
encore différent on n'est pas loin
d'arriver sur piton rouge et on a une
des premières stations d'altitude la de
ce fort à dénis data là c'est le petit
tamarin des hauts un arbre qui est assez
particulier qui pour ce qui peut
ressembler aux fleurs jaunes à certains
égards de par la couleur de ses fleurs
mais il a un port quand même assez puis
sonnant avec des toutes petites filles
de toutes petites feuilles beaucoup plus
petit que le fleur jaune et un verre qui
qu'on peut pas rater c'est un verre un
petit peu pâle un peu vert de gris ainsi
en fait qui est vraiment très différent
de celui du tabac et de haies de fleurs
jaunes
après avoir franchi ce petit raidillon
le piton rouge s'offre à nous anciens
codes éruptif en plein milieu de la
planèze un tracé à même sa pente invita
le gravir en douceur
le centre mais ruraux
dans l'eau de souhaits
là haut quand le temps est dégagé le
point de vue permet d'observer une
grande partie de la côte ouest ainsi que
l'eau de la planète vers le petit benare
et son réseau de sentiers qui peut
inviter à continuer la randonnée vers
d'autres objectifs
ce que j'aime dans cette randonnée c'est
que c'est une renommée qui n'est pas
très longue qui est accessible un petit
peu à tous ya pas beaucoup de portes
n'est pas très difficile et surtout elle
permet d'arriver sur une un point de vue
magnifique lac et le piton rouge même
sur lequel nous nous trouvons
actuellement la planèze a été quadrillée
par des tas de sentiers différents et l
avantage de du sentier d'aujourd'hui du
sentier de piton rouge c'est qu'il offre
la possibilité soit de faire un
aller-retour de rentrer à la voiture en
deux trois heures en comptant le pique
nique soit de continuer ensuite sur le
petit benare et sur le grand ménage si
on décide d'aller un peu plus loin
d'aller vers le petit veinard si on
passe par la caverne du roi france qui
est un lieu historique du marronnage
talus assez mystique aussi puisque les
créoles ont l'habitude de dire que les
esprits du roi phare ans hante encore
les ravines de l'ouest ce que j'aime
moins dans cette randonnée c'est
effectivement toute la première partie
qui est extrêmement vahid exotiques
comme on a pu le voir tout à l'heure les
acacias d'autres d'autres un autre
cortège aussi d'espèces exotiques qui
est assez présent et puis le côté un
petit peu casse pattes de cette
randonnée qui est quand même qui a un
côté assez minérale et poussiéreux de
par les incendies de 2010 2011 la france
a bouffé un petit peu de poussière sur
tout le long de la randonnée